それからこの 虚空精進というものがあります
それはまあ洞窟など 何かものがないところは虚空精進と言っています
で あの 次にこのこの次の説明に出てくるのはこの
例えばあのまあ空ではないんですね
動物とかね 穴とか何か言ったらそこに何かあるわけじゃないんです
何か無いんだ 無いことでまた言葉入れるんですね
で そこでそれあるようになってしまっちゃうんですね
洞窟というのは まあ土を掘って捨てるんですね
掘っ放しでもいいんですけどね
そこで地水火風をもうないようにしちゃうんですね
そこで地水火風がないところで
本当は何もないはずなんですけど
そこに名前を付けちゃう
名前を付けた途端 洞窟はあるんだということになってしまっちゃうんですね
ん？ 洞窟  洞窟はあるんだということになってしまっちゃうんですね
そこにもっと余計な損得があるんですね
この中に空気があるんですよと言っても
それは意味がないんです
空気はここら辺にもありますから
そこは関係ないんです
空気があるないことは関係なく
我々はこの土を掘ったところで
他のところで土でもう一応囲んであって
ないところがあって そこに名前を付けちゃう
そこでこの 真空状態も同じことなんですね
科学的に言えば 何もないところに名前入れたって真空状態そこでそこがあるようになってしまっちゃうんです
名前を付けた途端 だからこの名付けっていうことも勉強しなきゃ大変
もう誤解しやすい世界なんですね
だから仏教の世界も仏教はなんかもうとんいろんな方向へ変化して変化して仏教でなくなったのも
これこの言葉にすごくこの寄りかかったと引っかかったということでもあるんですね
だから言葉でないと喋れませんし
一旦言葉で喋った途端
そういうそういうものは実体としてあるんだという一般の人々の頭の働きがそうやってしてしまうので
だからこの言葉っていうのは知るための工夫なんですね
その知るための工夫だから
そこで知ってしまったら
知ったものはあるということになってしまっちゃうんです
で そこはさらに続けて
このそれで瞑想するときも
いろんな現象が現れるんですね
そういうものはすべて粗拙とだと仏教で言うんです
だからこのこの瞑想して
この何か神秘的な世界を作ってしまいますから
で これはインド文化ではものすごい厄介なもので
みんなこの何か神秘的な何か体験して
そこをそこは実体であって
他のものはそうじゃないと言いたがるんですね
ですから このヨーロッパの宗教も全部宗教はほとんど神秘的なもんですから
まあ科学とは縁がないんだから
だからほんのちょっと何か一般的には理解できないもの
一般常識で理解できないものなんかあったら
そこでもう絶対的にもう真理だと信じ込みすぎちゃうんですね
例えばまあ例えばキリスト教を信仰してる人がいて
自分の子供が熱を出して寝込んじゃっているんだと
で まあそれで夜薬もなくて
医者のところに連れて行くこともできない
そこでマリアさんにお祈りする
で 朝見たら子供は熱は冷めてもう何のことなく元気にまあお腹が空いたと
なんとか言っちゃうと
見たらもう大丈夫 治ってるんですね
で それだけのことですごくびっくりして
徹底的に信仰がもう徹底してしまっちゃうんですね
やっぱり何の治療もしなかったのに
子供が治してくれた で
まあそうやってこの神秘的なことで
そういうこのもう単純な神秘的なことにしたって
もう人のこの迷信っていうのは強くなる一方で
で もっとひどいのはインドの世界なんですね
まあいろんな変なことをやってますから
まあとにかく変なことをやるだけなんですけど
ほとんど 例えば人は食べるんだったら行者は食べないようにする
人は服を着るんだったら行者は服を着ないようにすると
人が家に住んでるんだったら
行者は家に住まないで
あのどこか山の中で もうあるいは空の下で生活すると
ですから冬になってくるとほとんど裸で外にいると
そうやって違うことをする
インドではずっと立っている
行は立っていることだけ
もう人がいて それから全く喋れないと
それは年 六年 十年とか続けてやるんですね
一言も喋れません テレビでやるの見たんだけど
この何て言いますか 猿
ハヌマンですか これ神だからね
で これ昔からあったインドのヒンドゥー宗教でもないんです
ほとんど最近できたもんで
あのバカどもそれさえ歴史的に勉強しないんだからわかってないんだけどね
で もう神のお使いであるのはハヌマンという猿という動物だから
もうそういうの神であって
自分が猿のように生活する
だから猿は服を着ませんだから本人は裸でいるし
体中この猿と同じく灰を吹きかけて同じ色で
で 食べるものは全部猿食べるものしか食べない
猿は喋れませんだから本人も喋れません
それで年なんもとかな
ずっとやってるんですね
それ年 年続けて頑張っちゃうと
他の人々は彼が仙人だと簡単に決めてくれるんですね
それで拝んだり いろいろ礼をしたりして
祝福を得ようではないかと
テレビで見た時は彼もインドの大きな祭りでありまして
この年に一回の それには参加すると
ガンジス川でね 結構人も死にますけど
あまりにもたくさん来るんだ
行くんだから 並の人々じゃないです
もうすごいんですから
で そちらでも行って この占ってあげたりはするんです
いろんな人が何か質問したら
答えてはしますけど 猿は喋れません
それでも人々が仙人だから
一生懸命足を触ったり
足を触っても こうやって頭に入れていろいろこの御利益を得ようとして
それでお布施いっぱいして
で 何か質問したら 彼が猿に猿もとか何とか言いますからね
そうやって何とか言うんです
言ったら隣に側近の人がいるんですね
彼が解釈してあげるんです
人間の言葉で ヒンディー語で
そこでピッタシ合いましたと
で インタビューしたら
本当に素晴らしく 私の質問をよく理解してちゃんと答えてくれたんだと言うんですね
だから問題はね あの猿の行やってる人が猿語で喋ってますけど
猿語は人間わかりませんだからね
インド人はヒンドゥーヒンディー語しかわかりませんだからね
一応ヒンディー語みんなわかってますからね
そこで質問した人はヒンディー語か他の言葉で喋ってるんだから
その言葉に翻訳しなくちゃいけない
通訳しなくちゃいけない
で 側近の人がちゃんと通訳する
通訳を聞いてよくわかりましたと
ぴったしと自分の質問に答えてくれたんだと
占いですから ほとんど
そうになりますけど 私だったらあの通訳する人を捕まえて猿の群れに連れて行って
あの猿は何喋ってるかと言ってくれと
言いたいんだけどね そこまで人間考えないのはおかしいんですけどね
だから猿の行やるのはやりやすい
猿の声真似するのもやりやすい
私も子供の時よくやってましたからね
猿の真似とか声の真似とかね
そこら辺にいっぱい猿がいましたし
だから家の前とかあっちこっちにね
下りてきたりするし だからもうこちら遊んでると
そこら辺に猿も来て遊んだりしますから
やっぱり結構顔見知りですか
ですからもう毎日聞こえているんだからね
猿の声を真似しようと思ったら
それはそれほど難しくはなかったんですね
それで だから猿の行やるのはやりやすい
問題はそれは翻訳することなんですね
だから平気で人は自分
本当はその二人も自分が全くインチキやってると知ってもない
気づいてもないんです
人を騙してお金取ってるんだということにさえも気づいてないんです
行者が真面目にもう苦行していますからね
何年間も 自分が正直だと思っているし
そこで通訳するバカもんもそう思っているでしょうね
だからこの言葉の世界
このパンニャっていう世界っていうのは理解しなきゃ大変なことになるんですね
まんまと騙されるんですね
騙されるも騙す側も騙してるとわかってないところは本人も騙されてるんだから
だからこの仏教の世界っていうのは
世の中のどんな宗教とも全く関係ない世界なんですね
ほんのちょっとでも 関係持つというならば
科学的な世界だけなんです
科学は唯物論なんですけど
それでもいくらかは一緒に生きられるんです
宗教とはなかなか一歩二歩も進めないんです
真理の世界じゃないんだから
で このそれでもサル教やったり
それから瞑想やったりするでしょうし
ですからいろんな当然いろんな経験というものは生まれるんですね
それは避けられないこと
土を掘ったと捨てたところで洞窟が現れるんだから
何もないところで 何もないということで洞窟が現れるでしょうし
そういうことで あの 何か他の人をやってないことをやったら
当然違うことをやったんだから違う結果が得られるんですね
そこをまたパンニャッティしなくちゃいけないんですね
何か言葉を作らなくちゃいけないんですね
それで言葉作っちゃうんですね
そこでその言葉一人歩きする
実体になってしまっちゃう
それで瞑想する時は まあ普通の生活と違うことをやってるんだから
普通にクワを持って土を掘っている時の経験と
何もしないで黙って体も動かさないで座っている時の経験はどうせ違うでしょうに
例えば冬は部屋の中で暖房をつけてテレビを見ている時の人の経験と
外に行って もう風が寒い
寒い風が吹いているのに
外でじっと体を動かさないでじっと目を閉じて待っている時の経験というのは違うんです
そこで不思議なことというのは
例えば部屋の中で暖房をつけてあったかい
あったかいんだと その人は外へ出て座ると
座って体はもう寒いんだから動かせませんし
じっと目を閉じて待っているとどんどんあったかくなってくるんです
寒さは感じなくなっちゃうんです
それは気持ちよくなるんです
それでこれ不思議だと
やっぱりそういう風に修行すると
そうやって大変な不可思議な世界が現れてくるんだということになってしまっちゃうんですね
そこでおかしい 論理的でないということは
人類ほとんど寒い時は暖房つけて
なんとかの形で部屋の中に
人類の中で一人二人だけ雪の上で座って瞑想する
その人の経験は真理であって
大勢の人々の経験は真理でないと
という風になってるんですね
あれなんかすごい不思議な
そこでこの瞑想するといろいろ光見えたりとか
あるいはいろんな目で見たことがないものを見えたりしたり
聞いたことがない声が聞こえたりする
そうすると そういう人々は自分がすごいことを体験したんだと思ったりする
だから仏教では瞑想するとそういう現象が現れることは認める
でもそれは全て世説だと
現代風に言えば幻覚だと
何も実際何もないんだ
だから本当は否定しているんですね
そうしてくる すると出てくる
このありがたがっている神秘体験というのはすべて
でもそういう体験 現れることは避けられないんです
土を掘ったらどうやって動物出てくることを避けられます？それは避けられません
で そこら辺説明するためにも
このパンニャッティはきちんと理解してほしがっちゃうんですね
で はっきり言うと 例えば音っていうのは耳に触れたところで
物質的な音という物質が耳に触れて頭に生まれる認識なんですね
もし耳に音を触れなくても
頭の中でその機能が起きたならば
人にとってはそういう音なんです
だからといって その音という何か物質が存在する必要はないんだと
だから幻覚は幻覚で まあ落ち着いて理解してほしがっちゃうんですね
じゃあ ニジュウキュウバンメニ キマ サッダ パンニャッティ
パンニャーパナト パンニャッティ パナナーマ
ナーマ カッマーディ ナーメーナ パリディーピター
サー ヴィッジャマーナ パンニャッティ アヴィッジャマーナ パンニャッティ ヴィッジャマーネーナ アヴィッジャマーナ
パンニャッティ アヴィッジャマーネーナ ヴィッジャマーナ パンニャッティ ヴィッジャマーネーナ ヴィッ
ジャマーナ パンニャッティ アヴィッジャマーネーナ アヴィッジャマーナ パンニャッティ チェッタ
チャッビダーホーティ
で このそこからこのまた言葉の使い方なんですけど
その使い方三つ六つあるんだと
これはネーミングなんですね
ネーミング 名前を付けること
やり方六つあるんだと
一番目はヴィッジャマーナ パンニャッティ
これは日本語訳では存在
世説になってますけど
ヴィッジャマーナ パンニャッティっていうのは
あるものに名前を付ける
例えばこの一番わかりやすいのは
例えば衝撃体で心があるんだと
心象が五十二種類だよと
二十八種類のルーパがありますよと言ったところで
そういうものは衝撃体として一応あるものなんですね
あるっていうのは変化しないものっていう意味ではなくて
それも現象で言えば現象なんですけど
因果法則に成り立ちますけど
まあ一応それぐらいのことはあります
山といってもそちらにあるのは地水火風で
家といったってもそちらにあるのも地水火風で
机と言ったっても そちらにあるのは地水火風という働き
それを科学的に考える科学の世界と同じで
まあ元素でできているんだと
元素はいろいろやり方でからくりをして組み立てたところで違うものが出てくる
水素が自分一人だけ出るとガスになっちゃうし
それは酸素というガスと一緒になったところで水になってしまっちゃうし
だからまあ水といってもそっちにあるのは水素と酸素であって
まあまあそんなもんなんですね
ですから このあるものに名前を付けると
その場合 学の科学の世界では
例えば水素 炭素 酸素と言っちゃうと別に
ただの名前なんですね
あるものにつけてる名前だけなんですね
だから水素と言ったってもいいし
別に他の名前入れたってもいいんです
番号をつけてあったっても
ね もし番号をつけた方がもっとわかりやすく簡単でしたかもしれませんしね
でもまあ 例えば私はもう勉強したことがないんだから
日本語でそういう元素にどんな名前で言うかさっぱりわかりませんし
番号をつけてあったならば
一番目二番目といったもうもっと
まあ一応ピエロディクテーブルというあのちゃんと配列はあるんだけど
それを勉強してないんだから知りませんしね
ですから 例えば地水火風というのは名前なんですね
ネーミングなんですね
ある働きに知というネーミングしている
だから何を言いたがっているのかというと
例えばパタウィという言葉一生懸命調べて
いろいろして その言葉の意味がパタウィという元素でなければいけませんということじゃないんだと
知という言葉をつけてますから
そこでありったけの文献を探して
知の漢字の意味は何ですかと
そこでまあ中国の文化でずっと長い間この漢字がどんどん変化していろんな意味で使っていて
そういう意味は必ずしも知という元素でなければいけませんということじゃないんです
ただ単に知と入れただけで
だから水という漢字を入れたんだから出て
これは必ずしも水でなければいけませんということじゃないんです
ある働きにあるエネルギーに
まあ適当に言葉を入れたんですね
例えば水槽って何でのその名前を付けたんですかね
まあ適当に付けただけでしょうね
水槽というのはまあどんな感じですか
水の素ですかね え？だから水素というのは同じことなんです Hydro
というのは水という意味なんです
まあそれはもうラテン語やらね
もうサンスクリット語やら
どこでもほとんど似ている言葉だからね
で サンスクリット語では発音が Hydro みたいに簡単ではないんですけど
難しいんですけどね で
まあ適当に考えたら そこで水が出来上がるんじゃないかな
なんとか思ったでしょうね
そこでね 命に関係あるんだから
あの 何て言います オキシジェン
何でしたっけ？酸素 で
漢字の酸素は見たことがないんだからわかりませんだけど
このオキシジェンというのは魂でしょ
結局 まあ一応大体そういうような意味で
名前付けただけで で 水槽と言ったんだからといって
水槽のガスばっかりいくら詰めたって
そこで水が生まれるわけでもないし
オキシジェンあるんだからってそこで魂あるわけでもないし
まあ魂の元と命の元といえば炭素なんですけど
ですから 名前とそのものは別にぴったしということじゃなくて
一応ラベルだけなんです
でも結構このラベルに引っかかってるでしょ
結局それで我々の理解がかなり遅くなって鈍くなって理解しにくくなっちゃうんですね
例えば怒りという言葉あるでしょうし
そこで人間 ざっくり怒りって何ですかとわかってないんですね
そこで心のある特色 ある働きにつけてるラベルだけなんです
それが いわゆるアビダンマでは明確に心が対象に反発する
対象を認識した瞬間に
認識しなかった方が良かったというふうに反発する
それに怒りというだけ
反発することを逆らう
働く心に生まれる逆らう機能に怒りというだけ
そこで仏教の教説になると怒りという漢字書いて
このように このようにこの漢字ができてあって
こういうこういうふうなことで説明しちゃうんです
もう無茶苦茶なんですね
関係ないんです それとこの漢字の意味と
そこら辺気をつけてほしいんですね
よくこの仏教の講義なんか聞いてると
もう一応懸命言葉で ありったけの言葉で言葉もきめ細かく分析して
そこで歴史までいって
で こういう意味だと 全くお釈迦様おっしゃっている意味とは全然関係ない
中国-- 中国人のくだらない考え方
そんなもの仏教に入れて入れしまっちゃうんですね
いわゆるくだらないっていうのは
一般人に別に一般的な考え方だから
だからそこは中国の人々もいくらか分かったんだから
かなりの大事な単語は翻訳しなかったんですね
涅槃とかね パンニャーとかね
そういう大事な単語はもう翻訳しなかった
それからブッダという言葉も
もうわざとなかった漢字を作って
そうするとどんな意味かさっぱり誰もわからないんですね
だからないという漢字と人という漢字ですか
それを合わせて まあそれはまあホウと読んでブッダにしてしまっちゃったんですね
人間ではないと 人ではないと
だから人ではない人なんですね
まあそういう工夫できたところで工夫しましたけど
ずっとこの言語だから
そんないい加減に操っちゃったら誰もわからなくなっちゃうでしょうし
だから世俗的な人々の理解しているところから
使わなくちゃいけないし
まあだからそこら辺ちゃんと勉強しておかないと真理に近寄れないんですね
言語の世界と まあその言語の働きと
どこまでそれ使えるかとかね
そういうことで この実際にある生起体の世界で
今まで勉強したものを全部言葉で勉強したんですね
地水火風やら心やら 心素のことやら
あの貪瞋痴やら無知やら
いろんな言葉を勉強したんだけど
それは実際にある働きにつけてるラベリングだけ
名札だけ それはヴィッジョマーナパンニャッティというんですね
2番目はヒソンサイセセッソ
アヴィッジョマーナパンニャッティ
全く存在しないものにも名前をつけたりする
例えば山は存在しない
川は存在しない 家というものも存在しない
いわゆる実体として真理としてあるわけじゃないんです
それで我々は家 山 服 いろんな言葉使ってますね
で 例えば色受想行識と言えば
それは実際に体五つでできているんですね
その五つにつけてる名前はソンサイセセッソなんですね
で 人間ですよとか 田中さんですよと山ですよという場合は
そういう風なものは存在しないんです
ですから それでも名前でそれを言うことはできます
もし富士山というものが存在するならば
なんで壁に描いているのを富士山だって言うんですかね
よく言うでしょ なんのこと？富士山ですって
だから本当は富士山はそこに存在するわけでもなんでもないんだけど
で まあなんとか頭はそう思ってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから 存在しない ないもの
これないものと言ったっても
このまるっきり架空という意味ではなくて
もうそこに認識しているんだから
何か目に触れてるんです
何か目に触れてますけど
それはまあ富士山というわけじゃないんですね
富士山がなんとかとか名前付けちゃうんですね
3番目 ヴィッジャマーネーナ・アヴィッジャマーナ・パンニャッティ
まあ一応こっちのセッスミを読みますからね
ヴィッジャマーネーナ・アヴィッジャマーナっていうのは存在
非存在 セセッス ヴィッジャマーネーナ・アヴィッジャマーナ・パンニャッティ
ヴィッジャマーネーナっていうのは存在しているあるものなんですけど
そのあるものからないものを作るんですね
例えば人を見て あ この人は先生ですと言うでしょ
先生ですっていうのは何という意味ですかね
そこにあるのは色・受・想・行・識という五つだけなんです
その色・受・想・行・識のある塊に
私たちは先生ですという全くないものを付けちゃうんです
田中ですという場合も同じなんです
田中ですというのは全くないものなんですけど
でもいい加減に付けたわけじゃなくて
そこに色・受・想・行・識があるんです
色・受・想・行・識という五蘊がある
五蘊があるんだけど その五に田中さんという
また他のところに色・受・想・行・識あるんですが
あるんですけど 五蘊と言ったとたんヴィッジャマーナ・パンニャッティ
そこで先生ですと言ったところで
ヴィッジャマーネーナ・アヴィッジャマーナ・パンニャッティ
実際にあるものからないもののラベリングを作る
例えば女です 男ですという場合も同じことなんです
人間二人持ってきたら
そこにも五蘊しかないんですね
色・受・想・行・識 もう一人も色・受・想・行・識なんですね
でもこの識の中で ある色・受・想・行・識の中でこのアビダンマ出てきたんですね
イッティバー・ルーパという
あのなんとかイッティバー・ルーパなんです
パーリ語で 日本語では覚えてないです
うん  178ページにバーワ・ルーパ二つ書いてますね
女性男性の性識ですね
で ただそれだけ ある色・受・想・行・識の塊と
またある色・受・想・行の塊二つあって
前にある色・受・想・行・識の塊の中で
識の中に女性と女性という識が入っていて
こちらは男性という識が入っていて
これほんのちょっとの働きだけなんですね
あるちょっとその物体が区別する
ちょっとした違う働きなんですね
その働きによって これは女性です
これは男性ですと言っちゃうんですね
だから女性です 男性ですというラベリング作るためには
ほんのちょっとの働きもそこであるんですね
うん